No, a Kamala Harris presidency would not be a victory for all women.
For so long, women have been coerced into thinking that
if there is a woman in power,
we need to support her, regardless of where she stands on policy,
regardless of what we even think of her.
It doesn't matter. She shares a gender with us,
so we need to have her back.
Truth be told, I think one of the most sexist,
misogynistic mentalities you can have about women
is that they are all the same
and they all need to think the same.
There's nothing empowering about feeling coerced
into celebrating a woman in a position of power,
regardless of where she stands on policy,
simply because of her gender.
There's nothing empowering about letting somebody's gender
override their personal character.
And truth be told, right now,
this country is right for any woman who wants to lead to do so.
We do not need to settle for
and rely upon women with whom we fundamentally disagree
to shatter glass ceilings for us.
A true,
genuine win is not if somebody with your same gender gets into power.
If somebody with your same values gets into power,
that is a win. So for millions of women across the country,
we do not share the same values as Kamala Harris.
We do not believe that she represents us.
We share a gender, sure, but that's about it.